i heard you guys had an exciting taxi
journey yeah so i
i convinced joey to get a taxi because
joey wanted to get the train home
because it's about like half the price
but you know it was like midnight it was
the day where connor and i were
streaming
at the trash taste office if you guys
saw on our twitch yeah but it was like
11 p.m when we finished yeah and i was
like [ __ ] getting the train home come on
joe let's get a taxi here must be
comfortable let's
you know it's late you know we just see
i don't know why you like
have this massive thing about like the
comfort in taxi it's not that much
it's not comfortable so much more
comfortable you say it as if it's like
business class versus economy honestly
that's the way i see it like
no no because also right now with the
rona going on i don't
if i can avoid getting a train i'll
avoid getting trained i understand that
but
for me like i would most like 90 of the
time
i would rather get like have have a
longer journey that i can actually do
stuff on because i can't do anything on
a taxi i look like i can do more on
attack i look at my phone and i
immediately just get caught do anything
on a train in japan yeah i mean you can
watch youtube videos you can be on
twitter no no no no no because i get
carsick because i don't know why i'm
sorry that your natural selection didn't
favor you jerry that's not my problem
well i'm not the only one god gets the
classic yeah i don't think the future i
think most i think most people get cast
yeah
how do you get i'm focusing on the the
youtube video
it's because it's because you can't see
outside so the inertia just [ __ ] you up
yeah because that's how you get cast i'm
not sure about the exact signs of car
sickness but i've
like cars are the only vehicle i get
motion sickness in
yeah anything else i can like read i can
vote
boats well that's not carsick is it it's
yeah that's she said vehicle
i don't think i get seasick really yeah
i get c6 yeah i guess slightly
seasonable
because normally people who are carsick
gets seasick yeah i mean i don't get
classic that easily though
unless you're watching something unless
but if i'm looking down on my phone or
like i can't
yeah no no like like i i i don't get car
sick if i'm just sitting there
listening to me hell then yeah it's
[ __ ] boring for you when you have to
travel like four hours in a car what are
you doing god i [ __ ] hate
my music and go to bed yeah that's why i
i think that's why i've conditioned
myself to be able to sleep so easily in
cars yeah
because i literally can't do anything in
cars and listen to music i can do the
exact same thing on a bus and not get
sick
on a bus yeah i could be on a bus and
watch youtube
or whatever or read i can look at that
[ __ ]
but i can't but i but if i do that in
the car
i think it's five minutes in i think
it's the smaller the vehicle the more
likely i'm
to get sick i don't know what the
science is behind that yeah but if it's
like a like this if it's like a small
taxi
especially if it's a small taxi and
we're like squeezed in then you find the
back seat right and if you're in the
backseat
i just get immediately i don't want to
go in the front of the taxi i don't want
to i don't want to make eye contact with
the taxi driver you don't have to
what do you think you're just going to
[ __ ] do these things well sometimes
you know you might find yourself
wandering and you look at him and it's
this awkward moment of like
hi i did no i never
i have the same problem in the back seat
where i accidentally sometimes
look at the like no that's the wall
sometimes look at the rear
mirror
the worst is when they're a [ __ ]
awful driver as well you got to pretend
like they're doing a good job
and they're just [ __ ] yeah and that's
why i prefer to be in the front because
i'm less likely to get sick in the front
from [ __ ] driving yeah in the back
because you're [ __ ] thrown around in
the back anyway the story so
yeah we were talking about the [ __ ]
yeah okay go back into taxi
yeah yeah so anyway so connor was like
look it's
it's 20 minutes home on a comfy
get closer to our house because we don't
have to go to the station walk right not
that much yeah so i was like all right
[ __ ] i'll humor your taxi ride
so then we get in the taxi taxi's
driving fine and then we go on to this
like kind of
bridge thing and uh and then
just some random police officer just
walks out onto the street
and kind of flags us down right and
tells us to go into one of the roads
and immediately the taxi driver was like
does the japanese equivalent of
oh [ __ ] he's like he's like this nine
year old dude just being like
oh [ __ ] and he pulls in and connor are
like what the [ __ ] going on
and i asked the taxi driver i'm like uh
something wrong and he's like
i was speeding i was like
what you got stopped for speeding and
he's like yeah i was doing 80 down to
60.
and this [ __ ] old dude just like
walks out of the taxi [ __ ]
like you know aussie osborne just like
kind of stumbles out
it's like four policemen surround this
old poor old man
yeah and like in the middle of the night
is he's filling out this paper
work and connor and i just kind of
sitting there being like oh we could
have been home by now if we weren't on
the train huh
the one time i humaned this man to get
on a taxi listen
i've ever had a taxi driver been pulled
over by the police you know
because i was like i was like i was just
hoping that they wouldn't be like all
right let's have a look at these these
boys in the back look
on with esports pretty foreign i was
like far come on yeah no i i was afraid
that might happen as well so
immediately like before the police
officer even started talking to us
i just immediately busted that japanese
what's going on
yes i am japanese also the police
officers asked us they were like is it
okay if we stop you for now
like the driver yeah yeah yeah and i was
like what what
what if we said no yeah i'm like what
are you supposed to say to that like
we're in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
there's no taxis anywhere what do you
expect us to do like they pulled us over
over some bridge so there wasn't like
much there so it was just like some
water right like a bunch of like a power
plant nearby so it was like nothing it
was really odd so
four police officers like [ __ ] just
found this decrepit
yeah just for this guy and then there's
two other police officers just standing
there doing nothing because that's what
they do here
every police officer every police story
i've heard in japan is
is all about how many police officers
you need versus how many was actually
needed
they literally sent like six police
officers to like you know someone
falling over on a bike yeah it's like
it's insane they're so bored here they
have nothing to do
yeah or they need you know spotters
right
i got you bro nice policing you're doing
that
yeah because normally the uk it's always
like two people like it's always a squad
yeah exactly for one yeah one in your
partner right yeah it's normally
how it should be right and you don't
because also this i i don't know if this
is on purpose but it's very intimidating
when four or five policemen are crowding
around you and you haven't done anything
and
they're asking you questions they all
look pissed off and i'm like well come
on what's going on here then
yeah all right that's all this about i
felt so bad for the old dude because he
he looked like he was about to get
[ __ ] and beaten up by his full police
officer
because they literally was just crowding
around him just like looking down
at the paperwork i was like i've never
been in this situation as well this is
the first time where i've been
near police where they haven't asked for
like my id and like information stuff
yeah
yeah yeah because i've busted out the
jackpot yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so
annoying cause you just go near them
they're like hey we see id and all this
and i'm like why i'm not involved in
this i'm literally just a customer
and leave me alone what do you think i
had a gun pointing to this thing
yeah do it do it do it do it you should
cut it
oh yeah no like what stop playing europe
in the background
hey come on drift this corner
i know what i'm doing i know what i'm
doing